[Music]
okay this last one we saw was Captain
Marvel which is a superhero movie or in
case you didn't know it was the origin
story for this character which I knew
nothing about this character I thought
it was a guy really I mean the character
is originally a guy one time Windham I'm
pretty sure originally Captain Marvel
was [ __ ] what the was the character was
a DC character that we know it's Shazam
I think that that was originally Captain
Marvel but that had some due rights and
he's yeah yeah I'm sure like something
yeah I think Captain Marvel was now
known as just a.m. or something but I
saw the movie what do you think of Jane
um I actually enjoyed it quite a bit I'm
not a huge superhero movie fan and I
have it like I've seen some of the
movies in the MCU you know probably saw
the first Avengers like the first Iron
Man stuff like that but I tend not to
see them until like years later it's you
know so so I'm not you know up on all
the stuff I know enough about it that
you know that I knew who this was and I
knew some of the peripheral characters
were and stuff like that so like I said
this is kind of like Captain Marvel's
origin story about Carol Danvers also
kind of the origin story of a shield and
Nick Fury said in 1995 so kind of a nice
soundtrack of the cold yeah that's and
breeders go in there everybody it's a
lot there's a lot of grunge stuff yeah
there's a lot of Nick Fury in this movie
it's almost a Nick Fury movie he has
co-starring in it and it's kind of like
Nick Fury's origin story to his service
I didn't realize this but they aged
regressed him yeah I could tell
I didn't yeah it looked good though cuz
I'm like yeah he's all know doc yeah
look good but I didn't notice
good job would you think of it July key
I did I enjoyed it quite a bit like I
said it's you know I'm not as super into
like the Marvel Universe so I don't know
like a lot of good so I'm sure somebody
that like super a joke will probably
enjoy it a lot more than me but I
thought it was fine I thought it was you
know kind of fun I enjoyed it the story
was pretty compelling
I actually liked and I know you're
probably gonna say you didn't like it
because it kind of jumped around a lot
but I kind of liked that aspect of it it
almost at the beginning of it almost had
like a Jacob's Ladder personality
whereas Khushi wasn't really sure what
her identity well it's like whether she
was very oh she's an alien like you know
what was this past that she kept having
these nightmares and stuff and you
weren't really sure we're a long time
like unless you read the comics I guess
you know whether you know which one was
the real thing like what her real
identity was so I was kind of like
compelled by that whole mystery but yeah
it's like I thought it was a perfectly
enjoyable film yeah I don't like
superhero movies so you know I don't
like them yeah some of the older ones
like the old spider-man's and [ __ ] like
that guy liked them but it progressively
the Marvel ones got more and more say me
and as an S don't really give a [ __ ] but
I did see venom I like that one and I
liked it was the name of that [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
Aquaman ness it was a that was awesome
yeah it was it was kind of like it was
kind of like Flash Gordon but this one I
just it was a mess it was just kind of
all over the place I really had a hard
time getting a feel for who this was as
a character I do feel he's just
something I have to have seen
because she's just some blonde chick
really I don't know who this woman is
really you know there's no real
personality side to her
she's a son and it was just very generic
if you yeah I don't think I like that a
battle angel was a lot better just I
thought it was just a lot better yeah
it's gotta say but like I said you know
I thought it was perfectly fine I think
a lot of it I think a lot of problem
whether it was the hype I think he's
kind of built up you don't make you a
Tomo how great how important this movie
were not [ __ ] important matches well
I think it's kind of like it's not
important there leading up to yeah
Avengers end game so they had to like
yeah like I said I'm not it was just
generic to me to me it's just another
generic movie yeah it uh it has some
good gunfights in it but then they
started talking when they start talking
it throws me out of it because I really
care what you're saying they're trying
to be deep and I'm like managed it isn't
deep at all but yeah
mediocre I'm gonna say it's not my says
bad as mediocre yeah I think I doubt of
the two I take battle Angela's looking
twice as good that was a story there and
I had that have a story to tell it was
kind of yeah generic
you
okay just got done seeing one called
Warner Park which was an animated film
for kids and I was done by a Nickelodeon
studios
about the soul girl who goes to a
magical land scenic if I explain it's
kind of like Wizard of Oz in a certain
way heard her mom has like invented this
part in their education yeah and her mom
is sick and has to go to hospital yeah I
thought she died so she gets sad and
doesn't want to work on the park anymore
and then she goes off on a trip and ends
up like magically transporting to a park
and all of her little stuffed animal
friends have come to life and are like
we don't know what's going on with the
park like this darkness game is
everything up and all these little
chimpanzees like yeah a little animated
a little buggies were like tearing the
park
I can't believe we're talking about this
boat okay yeah yeah you could think
about these movies is that an adult
could sit through them they won't drive
you [ __ ] crazy okay they're not as
bad as
movies for kids when we were kids that
would drive your parents crazy oh yes
but so but a dog could go to cities in
Canada you know maintain sanity the
moral of the story on this one was just
you know don't get depressed because
then you can't create things that's that
was that was pretty much essentially it
because that was like the whole thing I
mean the darkness was like she thought
that you know she couldn't use her
imagination for vacation she felt so bad
and she realized that it had like
implication is like further outside
herself you know so it's actually pretty
cute like I really I liked the way they
animated it it's almost kind of like you
know how some of the like Pixar ones and
they're like really slick and like have
a lot of sheen and stuff which this had
but it also had like a lot of shots that
were like she's like shaky-cam and stuff
like yeah it had like this really weird
like look to it so it looked almost
realistic but not so I thought that was
kind of interesting and no it's a cute
story it's not as I think it's not as
like ironic or sarcastic as maybe some
of Pixar ones or you know maybe like
elimination studios or something would
do it definitely is seems like it for a
slightly younger audience although like
I said it did have some kind of darker
aspects to it which I wasn't really
expecting but I you know I quite enjoyed
it I have to say what my very favorites
in this I busted out laughing was when
she goes after her mom goes up to the
hospital and the little girl name is
June she goes to she's gonna go up to
math camp but then on the way there she
thinks her dad is gonna be like burned
the house down while he's by himself
because he's a man that he has video and
a duty may be good so she wants to go
back so she's like imagining him like
late for the stage like inhaling pizzas
there piece of boxes like there's crows
inside the refrigerator blows that yeah
that that scene actually very much that
will happen yeah it was a well made
movie you could take the kid to go see
it he won't drive it crazy both oh who
gives a [ __ ] but a 50 year old man says
buy this what I'm not about you intended
oh honey it's we actually went you know
we don't care because we don't think we
have news but we went to go see in 3d
yeah and I was like they're not telling
us about the 3d glasses out yeah yeah I
was never thirty was not 3d and so about
10 minutes in like somebody came in it
was like sorry yes right yeah yeah you
can take your kid to go see it yeah kids
relax I think that's really cute and
like you know the little chip man things
work you don't little characters all
right
all right we just got done seeing one
called captured state captive captive
state yeah it was uh about the earth got
invaded by aliens and they hooked up
with the rich people and they were
underneath the earth strip mining the
earth down at nothing there in a few
years it was gonna be destroyed you know
at the rate that they were going and
that was the situation and then there's
like a resistance a human resistance to
try to fight these things off because
material when they first invaded the
military was just - pretty much defeated
instantly so this is just about a minute
surgeons yeah this is like a there's
actually yeah same premise like same
premise actually as they live I was
thinking yeah this is very much a
similar vein that they live or district
9 it gave me like a little bit of a tone
of that all right you get to see some of
the aliens you can see the ships look
like a big honeycomb things and
honeycomb ships made out of rock and you
see aliens that look like sea urchins
shaped like human beings and
weird-looking predator looking things in
armor but there actually was not very
lot wasn't very much of it I really
didn't think there was enough aliens
there should have been more of them it's
hard for me to tell what kind of movie
this was it wasn't an action movie it
was more of a cloak-and-dagger type yeah
yeah it almost kind of like a weird
heist movie context or a spy movie
because I mean the aliens were there and
they were like in the background but you
didn't really see much of them it was
mostly about the characters and the
network of the insurgency and how they
went about you know the particular plan
that they're gonna do like to try and
fight back against the alien and the
human cops trying to stop answers yes so
that's pretty much I mean so don't come
into this
thinking that it's gonna be like this
big like sci-fi like Independence Day
yeah nothing like that it's pretty much
just like like I said district 9 they
live to have that kind of tone yeah but
maybe not even is like probably the same
thing live was like goofy but it was
kind of goofy though it was kind of
goofy but they know it was yeah it's
like just the aliens are just very very
much in the background you just every
now and that you see their ships you see
them there it's flakes and stuff like
that but they're not really in that many
scenes it's just always kind of this
oppressive foursome of like people
talking about them they like I said it's
it's mostly based around the characters
that are trying to fight back against
them they live was goofy but it was fun
fun too way yeah
this one was realistic and kind of slow
I thought I I didn't really like it that
much I thought it was kind of boring
I wasn't my kind of movie yeah I liked
it but I can see you're saying it was a
little kind of slow moving oh yeah it
was like this it's like I said I'm not
gonna say believe it was a sci-fi action
movies more like a dystopian yeah
thriller I want to say that is probably
more kind of you know way of putting it
if they had dumbed it down speeding it
up and put some more action and I would
like to I'm not here to get involved you
know I'm talking I'm just here to have a
good time although I have to say I did
like to look at the aliens it reminded
me a little bit there's a horror movie
it's either on that what's your shutter
called splinter or splinters and the
monsters that kind of reminded me of
that where they were kind of like
liquidy but then they weren't like hills
like yeah like a sea urchin like you
said yeah they're kind of a sea urchin
shaped like a human being yeah you only
have a 10 times enemy only that was a
suit yeah it was he said they got pulled
off you can see the face it was just
yeah and then it looked like kind of an
anus yeah well it actually looked like
the center of the of a scene here yes so
yeah they did make up
yeah but like I said it's if you're I
think you'll like it if you're going
into it not thinking it's gonna be like
I said if you go into it thinking it's
more like I said like a slow moving yeah
like spy thriller kind of thing if
you're on a list if you're on a list
then you got you got to have something
to watch anyway so you know you better
they just not saying yeah it's better
than not it's better than not seeing
anything yeah
we're seeing some worse than this yeah
why not
[Music]